Esports legacies can be tricky obviously
competitors want to be remembered by
Future Generations but sometimes whether
it's a team effort or an individual
achievement the things they're
remembered by can be kind of
embarrassing how many players are going
across pure silence
today we're going to look at some of the
more unfortunate Esports records out
there but before we get into it I have
to remind you guys check out our merch
Link in the description but now let's
get on with our list
Pros tend to die a whole bunch in CS go
as long as they return the favor though
their teams are generally okay with it
devices had a really rough game flashed
he's gonna get that shot and it has to
feel a little bit going out middle of
the air to take down Alex another
pushing oh
[Music]
every single one from nothing to the
awpas but when someone's KD difference
dips thousands of points into the red
it's understandably alarming and amongst
Pros with the greatest KD differences
around hundin holds the dubious honor of
being at the very top of the list
according to hltv stats
them getting ahead of themselves them
stressing out a little bit and you can't
make those mistakes against Bad lines
hunting though they've taken the entire
map away from the defensive side and
switch sides oh no oh that's the bomb as
well
and then wow he's not normally renowned
for his old ping but I guess it's better
he's gonna go down to the flames and say
Carrigan now with the triple kill he has
been putting up numbers London
needs to try and basically just Escape
he was hoping to maybe catch a kill on
the way out get himself an extra
a little bit of money I think the plan
there was to maybe trade out the uh
smoked in order to get the kit but it
didn't matter in the end he's gonna be
killed off as bad as this record is
though in his particular case hunting is
more likely to be remembered for that
other thing he did I've got this game
loaded up it's heroic versus astralis
it's the match where hundin for the
first 10 Rounds
uh had a coach camera or had a camera
and free cam on banana
biggest gold advantage in Dota 2's
history is an amazing achievement uh
yeah I don't know how do I hold this
you're gonna have to try and attempt to
fade blink 4 to find the Knight stalker
protect the disclaimer's wall to pop the
Lincolns are gonna be careful if they
ride on the back line here because the
throne's exposed the initiation wasn't
there at the moment yank wants to drop
the arena traps in three with the pkbs
I'm just gonna try and turn to the
background yours he's hunting as Triple
C he's able to provide a little bit of
distance but that semi's falling low
they're gonna be careful set to proceed
it's getting melted by the knights oh
God that might be it turn it down xm's
back inside the base but the throne's
gonna pop as elephant they take it just
over 80 minutes 154
000 net worth lead I am speechless but
what gets off and overlooked in cases
like bees is the fact that there is a
team on the other side of the equation
as well elephant definitely did
something worth being proud of for a
long time to come whereas ehome now
Bears the dubious distinction of losing
to the biggest gold disadvantage that's
rough
sometimes it's just not your day or your
year or even your game really former
Swiss CS Pro solac had a pretty spotty
record when it came to in-game
performances to the point where it
became a bit of a meme in the CIS
Sonic Sonic
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what makes solex 0.04 rating on nuke as
the absolute worst single map
Performance out there is the 0 to 20 KD
score that went along with it yeah they
should be around for them but team here
in defense could be a troublemaker
getting one kill
solic is wired too tight right now and
it's not like no fear goes for pimp runs
out of bullets whips out the knife and
that is going to be the pistol round for
Nostalgia both pistols going their way
but stalik is now going to get smoked
off from garage and this denies the
information he knows that somebody's out
there but now he actually has nothing to
work with here this could come down to
whether Apex is going to look the right
way when he comes around this box but
they just managed to miss each other I
mean and he goes back and Alex Apex gets
the first kill
speaking of 0 20. DOTA 2's milk Is
tragically familiar with that score line
in a semi-finals match between EG and
mouse Sports melk's kill death record
was 0-20 but somehow his team still
ended up winning a role you want to go
they have 10 seconds this is a very
short time frame
Lacoste wants to go in for a black hole
as well but none of the people is there
and the first one to die is milk okay
the only one to dye is milk yeah and
morphling had to rebind that as well and
not that it matters for his items
because he's pretty much full
um although he might need to swap
something around now milk has even got
all China's score
melk is level 18.
and he's calling out that the goal for
him is to be level 25 before the game
ends no no no
it's 25 deaths men he's only got 19.
he's actually got more he's got more
destined levels
from then on anyone who dies 20 or more
times without killing any of the players
on the opposing team gets the so-called
milk award to their name which come to
think of it means our previous entry
qualifiers congratulations man Silver
Linings
this one's just the record for us with
short attention spans one of the
shortest rounds in Pro CS go a whopping
8.38 seconds to try to make something
happen which means they if they wouldn't
have done that maybe they could have
actually mustered up since I have to buy
this round
um so that does hurt them a little bit
here just trying to get on the last one
now they're just all gonna push middle
it's gonna be like shooting ducks right
now Oscar playing a duck hunt for Middle
with Chris J I'm not sure what that was
hoping to accomplish I should mention
there are other contenders like a seven
second round between crazy and nordvand
and European minor qualifiers but faze's
stupefying decision to rush mid and
basically line up to be picked off by
Mouse sports during their ESL Pro League
match makes it the shortest round of pro
CS Go played by a top tier team I did
not want to see that guys that's that is
that was tough that's like watching
adults beat up children
my goodness that was not fun to watch
V3 Esports have recently set a record
for the longest losing streak in League
of Legends history
0-39 after not winning a single game
since the 2021 ljl summer playoffs I
think we can all agree that is one
horrible losing streak luckily for V3
they managed to pull one out at the 11th
Hour just before they risked overtaking
a roster notorious for having the
absolute worst win loss record in all of
Esports ever I'm talking of course about
OverWatch League's Shanghai dragons
wrapping around the backside he's found
another one old tricks missing making
three variety to cutie oh he'll take
four and the winnebaker coming to life
and that'll do it the San Francisco
shock will sweep the series four and
zero
for the dragons man it has been a long
season a tough season many lessons to be
learned they will be back next year and
I'm quite sure this experience will be
valuable for them and you know what even
more importantly Matt they walk out of
this place with dignity because they get
up on this stage every single week and
they do their very best but it was not
enough against the shock to make matters
worse well 0-40 was the number that
earned the Chinese team the unfortunate
distinction they didn't stop there but
spark edging that payload even closer to
finishing this one they've got the
aggressive positioning we're into
overtime spark trying to win the match
Shanghai dragons just trying to stay
alive let's get grease out of the neck
and there goes in the shadow coming in
to seal the deal and they've got the
sound barrier on top of that it looks
like today is still not Shanghai today
the spark will get their first win in
their first match in the OverWatch
League after reaching the big 4-0 in
season one the dragons lost two more
games at the start of season two
bringing their total uninterrupted
losses to 42 games it seemed like like
there was no stops there losing streak
but it all came to an end when they
finally won their first match on their
43rd attempt
Ed
coincidence is out from Aim God but it's
going to expire they will be able to
finish
him off of the Primal race but it does
not matter ladies and gentlemen history
has been made and this concludes our
list of some of the most embarrassing
records in Esports history but of course
there's always room to do worse so if we
missed one let us know down in the
comment section below take care of y'all
and I'll see you in the next one have
you seen have you seen the meme that's
like
like you guys like want to Forfeit right
and it's like my 3 and 17 chamber and
it's like John Cena getting the never
give up towel
uh I used to have a giant crush on John
Cena when I was younger
yeah and then I found out he was married
at the time I had a crush on him